and I always find it shocking when
people do come to the show and the first
thing they say is wow that was that was
really good no like their shock it would
be like right right right oh man you
know I didn't want to come that was
grilling kind of good yeah right
I love that one I've always hated you I
hate comedy but you're it was good it
was It was kind of fun it was kind of
yeah it was actually pretty good
actually it's doing pretty good feeling
good thank God because I thought it
[ __ ] blue
how does that work were you touring
before and then all sudden you get a
Vegas residency or yeah how does that
work like you've been doing the The
Comedy Club Circuit yeah we were doing
yep we're doing that we're doing all
that doing clubs and colleges that was
my main thing colleges I do I do two a
day
literally I do one in the morning at
like a cafeteria and literally it was
there was one in a Breezeway one time I
said where's the stage I said right
there I said in the Breezeway and they
said yes I mean people like walking into
their classes and you know I'm standing
there hey here's a doctor working
bathtub toy
and uh and then at night you do this big
huge Auditorium you know like you know
in Penn State right you're in this 3000
seat thing and then
you go yeah so it was crazy the college
thing really is what made me uh get out
there and The Roots You Know marketing
then started slowly getting a little you
know a little television I had some 18 T
commercials which kind of funny talking
about you're talking about you're
getting recognized
from the podcast and I used to do these
at T commercial and they were there
everywhere they were like the
progressive ones now they're on every
eight seconds and I used to always see
people I hate them too and I try to make
as many as I can so at least there's new
ones to hate and um people are coming to
me in the mall like we're in town I'd be
playing at and they say oh my God what
are you doing what are you doing in town
yes I said I'm doing a show and they
said a show like a phone show and I said
yeah [ __ ] phone show no it's a it's a
comedy show they only thought that I I
was happy phones they had no idea that
it was a comic
and it was just it was really weird
there wasn't like a lot of people right
like I didn't know you were a comedian I
thought you just a sales person for ATT
so it was a whole new world of people
that would come in and see shows not
knowing that I actually had like an act
or something right and that was 18t
commercials like in the what year like
1990s probably and we had a collect call
you know and my basic audience was
Prisoners
I'd say that in the set like no who's
who are we working to prisoners to me
but uh right yeah but I was lucky to
have the gig you know and then to answer
your question yeah from that you slowly
get into I got um
weird how I got to Vegas I was doing
Regis and Kathie Lee of all shows and
it's you know nine o'clock in the
morning and I do this I do the show like
and I did great and I came off and this
this guy walked over and says wow that
was tremendous I've never seen you and I
said oh cool he says You must you must
kill in Vegas
and I said never played Vegas and he
says you've never played Vegas and I
said nope he says what the [ __ ] you are
Vegas and I said oh well I've never
played and he says if I book you in
Vegas would you do would you do it and I
said of course I'd do it I'm a [ __ ] I'm
a comic what do you mean when I'm doing
so the uh the guy came here and said I'm
gonna book you and it was Kathy Lee
Gifford's manager so they called Bally's
and they got me in the club of the first
time
and then uh I did literally Friday night
I did really well it was just a little
comedy club and the guy says hey we want
to put you in the big theater and this
is I've never I mean Vegas is different
than Penn State where there's a whole
full of kids screaming and Bong jokes
and whatever you want
you know this is Vegas and it's you know
a whole different audience and I and he
says we're gonna put you in the big
rooms like 3 000 seats I was terrified I
mean literally terrified and I got there
and it was
you know booths which is the killer of
Comedy really people sitting in a booth
though you want you want them sitting in
chairs in a booth they're gonna fall
asleep and you know eating a steak
dinner whatever the [ __ ] they do so I
bombed I mean pretty much bombed
horribly like I wanted to get out of the
business and um
I did that for a year at Bally's but in
and out bombing every night and uh
and then the MGM Grand called and said
you want to move to our room and it was
like an intimate 600 that's where David
copfield the joke of my show is I used
to play the MGM until David cropfield
had me disappear but um literally he did
he said I want and then people are like
oh that's funny he actually called the
newspaper or called me and said why did
you say that in the newspaper and I said
what he said I made you disappear I
didn't make I said it's a goddamn joke
dude you're you're so in a sense he made
me disappear because he wanted the room
you know you know Copperfield Carrot Top
so I I stayed there for and it was 10
years 10 years at the MGM but were you
really bombing yeah but Bally's well no
or do you think I think I was because
it's this huge room and I I was so used
to this thundersen college kids going
crazy yeah and people in Vegas you know
we just saw a building blow up we don't
really care about your your [ __ ]
cowboy boots with a kickstand on it or
whatever joke I would have so I was
doing better than I thought but it was
not it was uncomfortable a painful
uncomfortable and then I got to the MGM
it's a little better it's more intimate
but Vegas was still a different audience
I it took me forever to to get used to
an audience in Vegas right yeah that
David Copperfield was was going into a
600 seat theater he's doing it now he's
still in it really yeah he does 18 shows
a day I I'm not kidding I haven't said
him can you can go for a hike do
something but why do you do five shows a
day
he says why do you do one I said because
I have a life
one shows enough man yeah one show a day
yeah one show with David Sunday have one
day off Sunday yeah yeah and then I get
a week off
every uh every month so I go to Florida
and I have a house there cool man how
long do you do that for
uh how long have I done that no no yeah
I mean like is there a consistency
because like yeah four weeks on one week
off four weeks yeah on average
look my manager has a car payment so I
have to I have to keep working I can
keep working
yeah you said you do a lot of TV to
George Carlin by the way who got one of
my all-time you know well yeah and I it
was same room I was I was coming in and
he was coming out and um
I love this story because it's so weird
he come off stage and I was standing
there in the wings and he sees me and he
says uh hey get a kid and I say don't I
said I'm starting tomorrow no what are
you doing here as I'm starting I'm just
watching I was trying to steal some of
your act and he kind of laughed you know
still my [ __ ] kids you know whatever and
I said um and what do you start said
tomorrow how many shows did you do I
said one and then I do two on the
weekends he goes what are you doing the
weekends and I made that joke I said my
manager has a car payment so I you know
and he goes oh really why the [ __ ] do
you do two shows and why do why
and I said well I figured if I if I [ __ ]
up the first one I get a second shot at
it he got all my face never give the
audience the [ __ ] up or never ever
shut your cut yourself short you do your
[ __ ] and you [ __ ] do the way you do
it they don't like it [ __ ] them and he
walked off and I was like well that went
well you know and um I looked at this
man dressed I'm gonna go and he said no
no dude he [ __ ] loves you just
staying he wouldn't even he wouldn't
talk to you like that if he didn't love
you and sure enough I waited around five
minutes he said hey
brought me back in his room and we
didn't talk about anything else it's
just just life he didn't talk about that
he didn't even asked about my comedy he
just said it was a fan
he said I like that I like your [ __ ] I
had a joke that he said I like that [ __ ]
out of the [ __ ] is a great joke it was a
it was a a telephone
paper cups and string telephone you know
the old cup yeah and I used to do this
is a long time ago I said they did a new
version you know the updated version of
the stupid paper cups is string right
there should be one for today's world
and I have a second cup that came out
for call waiting
hey yeah I'll call you back I'm on the
phone and then I have like three cups it
was conference calling and then it was
it was a clear cup for caller ID I know
it's you [ __ ] I'm looking at you pick
up and he [ __ ] loved it he kept
saying that's [ __ ] funny as [ __ ] I
said thanks George thank you yeah George
Carlin's it man yeah yeah and for him to
you know to give you the blessing right
you know so I always that's how I kind
of going back to what you said earlier
about people [ __ ] on me is um right
at the end of the day when they do or
someone does I always think to those
moments you know I mean some guy is in
his Attic in Nebraska is saying I
[ __ ] suck and then you got George
Carlin saying you're funny [ __ ] right
that's how you keep that's how you keep
your sanity it's called Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're at ranked number
30 on all of Amazon and if you buy a
bottle we might go up the ladder and
that would mean a lot so please get on
Amazon and buy Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole yeah